there's been a lot of press coverage
about people quitting their jobs
well today's report tells you why
here president biden is referring to the
labor department's monthly jobs report a
key gauge of american employment and
inflation the report can move trillions
of dollars in market trades and
influence policy decisions like interest
rates at the federal reserve but the
report still has its limits there are
some things that the drop support just
doesn't include and because of that
we're not getting a complete picture of
the us jobs market
here's what you need to know to read the
monthly jobs report including what it
tells you and what it doesn't
the report which is normally released on
the first friday of the month gives a
look at the current state of the economy
and while economists read it in depth
there are four key areas that they tend
to focus on
non-farm payrolls often simply referred
to as jobs shows the number of positions
added or lost each month that aren't in
agriculture
this chart shows non-farm payrolls over
the past decade you can see job numbers
had been steadily rising until the
pandemic hit when they plummeted
and although jobs had started to recover
by late 2021 job growth had slowed weak
job growth can be a reflection of two
different things
one is that businesses are struggling to
find workers which is largely what we
saw in 2021 sarah cheney kanban reports
on the american labor market for the
wall street journal the other is that
demand for their goods and services is
weak and therefore they're laying off
workers or not hiring
this fluctuating jobs number is directly
tied to the unemployment rate which
measures how many workers in the labor
force are unemployed and currently
looking for work the goal is full
employment which some economists say is
around a four percent to five percent
unemployment rate full employment is
basically
when anyone who wants a job can get a
job when the unemployment rate is really
low
it's
generally a good thing it means that
businesses are not laying off workers
and wages are probably growing pretty
strongly as a result of low joblessness
but if unemployment drops too low it can
signal challenges the downside of low
unemployment can be that companies are
really struggling to find workers and
that can lead to them
raising wages and therefore prices and
you could get very big inflationary
pressures when the unemployment rate
goes down economists look into how much
of that is due to workers getting jobs
and how much is due to shrinking labor
force participation which is measured by
the labor force participation rate or
how much of the overall population is
either currently working or looking for
a job you can see labor force
participation has steadily declined over
the past two decades with the largest
drop happening at the beginning of the
pandemic and when the rate drops too low
it can put pressure on employers
generally when the labor force
participation rate is low as it's been
throughout the pandemic
you might see stronger wage growth and
that's because businesses just can't
find the workers to fill their jobs
they're oftentimes facing what we call
labor shortages and as a result they
ramp up pay
increasing or decreasing pay is measured
by wage growth
look at this chart you'll notice that
wages picked up in 2021 due to labor
shortages and economists expect that
wages will continue to rise
metrics like wage growth give economists
a sense of how the economy is doing but
the data only shows part of the picture
that's because the report is mainly just
hard data which means it can tell us
whether job numbers and wages are going
up or down but it doesn't explain why it
doesn't give us details on how good a
given job is it doesn't tell us how safe
a manufacturing job is or how well an
employer is treating their employees
and there's also the timing of the
report it's based on two core surveys
from the labor department
one of household populations and another
of employment data that take place
around the 12th of every month and as a
result the jobs report primarily
reflects the labor market over these
first two weeks which means there's a
delay in the data
the employment survey collects data from
around 145 000 employers some of whom
may respond to the survey late or not at
all before the pandemic hit
businesses were open and so they were
able to provide responses to the labor
department survey after the pandemic
hits a lot of businesses shut down
either because consumers stopped going
to ex-restaurants or ex-business or
because of government mandated
restrictions if businesses don't respond
the labor department has to guess their
payroll size which can get tricky and
this is what we saw happening during the
pandemic the labor department had a
smaller sample size of businesses to
work with for its payroll survey and as
a result the margin of error when
they're making calculations was higher
this margin of error is important in
part because of just how big the labor
market is in december 2021 it stood at
almost 150 million jobs if the number of
jobs added or lost are tens of thousands
higher or lower than what the report
shows it could make policymakers jobs
harder the federal reserve is really
closely watching those job growth and
payrolls growth numbers and if there's a
big margin of error they might have a
slight misunderstanding what's going on
still the fed looks at multiple data
reports about the economy and over time
estimates from the jobs report that are
too high or low tend to even out so the
implications are shorter term but
despite the pitfalls the jobs report is
still one of the most influential
indicators we have for the american
workforce and economy